CARTER MORGAN:
Today, we're talking
about contextual traces
for Cloud Logging, Cloud
certifications, and NEXT '21.
I'm Carter Morgan.
And welcome to "This
Week in Cloud,"
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
The need for relevant and
contextual telemetry data
to support online services
has grown in the last decade
as businesses undergo
digital transformation.
Distributed tracing
is a key capability
for improving application
performance and reliability,
as noted in SRE best practices.
Today, we're making
it easier for you
to understand what is happening
within your applications
by making trace information
available directly in Cloud
Logging.
This past August,
50 service members
began a 12-week Google
Cloud-sponsored certification
learning journey towards
achieving the Google Cloud
Associate Cloud
Engineer certification.
Participants had access to
online, on-demand learning
assets, biweekly
technical review sessions
taught by Google
engineers, and mentoring
through Google Groups.
To learn more about
this initiative
to help upskill veterans
for an evolving job
market and the value of
Cloud certifications,
check out the blog.
If you missed the
fun from NEXT '21,
you're now able to check out
all that content on-demand.
From keynotes to demos,
click on the link
to be a part of the action.
What a year.
As 2021 winds down,
we're preparing for 2022
by taking a deep breath and
looking back at all we've
accomplished since January.
We hope you'll take the
next few weeks to do
what you can for yourself.
And we'll see you in 2022
with the lowest latency news.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.